matt has sketched out a few things
already and we're gonna be talking about
you know taking advantage of VMware on
the cloud but a little bit of a focus on
lift and shift as well as transforming
so Matt real quick what do we have
graphed out over here so right here is
we're kind of picking up from where we
left in our last webcast that we did
with Jordan where we talked about more
just lifting and shifting the
application Rijo stting it if you will
where we're more concerned about how do
we get the application and the VM
without changing anything about it into
the cloud as quickly as possible and and
extending that VM and and all the
network policy and everything underneath
it into the cloud for consistent
operations with on-premise and in the
cloud right so last time you know we saw
that with things like hcx it was fairly
easy to read host capabilities from a
VMware running on-prem to something
running in the cloud right so that's
that's what we have yes right here you
have an unprepped what that site is
supposed to represent and then after
lift and shift you have your in the
state called cloud hosted like like we
talked about where it's just more moving
the application without changing
anything about it just to get the
tactical benefits and the elasticity of
moving to the cloud and you know what
we're talking about back at the at the
desk is that by Rijo stting first and in
and having your application live in the
cloud brings a host of advantages in
terms of the app modernization because
right now we're just focused on getting
on the latest and greatest
infrastructure that the cloud has to
offer right and then after that taking
advantage of the automation and the and
the scalability and the standardization
of the cloud to layer on more services
like open shift and like any other
kubernetes services out there so that's
that's kind of this you know this time
frame that we have laid out here right
so every step of the way you know you're
starting on prem you're taking that next
step to cloud hosted right and now
what's what's that next step like from
that last from that last kind of webcast
that we did we understood there was a
lot of capabilities helping us here but
you know at the end of the day customers
want to take advantage of higher value
services right and capabilities that you
can get in something like IBM cloud
exactly they want of like we're talking
about they want to bring start
introducing cloud native services and
then get it just as an organization get
more adapted to the the value of being
in the cloud right and the elasticity of
that so at that stage we are now
at what we call the when try to make it
a nice square here at cloud-enabled is
what we call it animal and in this phase
we are now taking advantage of being on
the the cloud network right because now
you're in the IBM clouds or the cloud in
general whatever club that maybe you're
in there private network you're taking
advantage of the services that are on
the the private endpoints and such as
you know object storage or analytic
services that might not require changing
the application too much you can still
keep it in a VM and I'm like plug and
play services exactly exactly and you're
not you're not refactoring the
application just yet so from the
application level you're you're
enriching it as much as you can from the
infrastructure level you're taking
advantage of the the consumption models
that the cloud has to offer and using
things as needed
you know we mean by basically your VMs
are continuing to run in a cloud
environment but now you're kind of
reaching out and taking advantage of
some of these cloud cloud propositions
those cloud service exactly exactly to
the extent that it can with the
application in it's probably most likely
it's in a three-tier architecture right
you have your your web tier your app
tier and your database tier right and as
much as you can integrate services that
and and at that that kind of
architecture you're taking advantage
that anything in the cloud enabled stage
right so now it's less about just lift
and shift and more about transform right
maybe you have to get in there sometimes
change some things around call some
third party API right you know yeah that
kind of thing exactly and then after you
know you've you've you've from an
operational perspective you're more
adapted in and and ready to take the
next step there's where we introduced
open shipped in kubernetes you know you
have this VM where a state that now
lives in the cloud you have the VMS
there you have your legacy applications
living on top of them now you can start
to think about Reap platforming or even
Rijos or it's not Rijo Singh you can
start architecting or refactoring the
application so here you'll see that
we'll have the VM here and and then
you'll see that we have we're gonna use
a container right here so this is what
we're going to use to to label a
container and this is still kind of your
you know you're not fully cloud native
yet so we're gonna call this cloud
enabled as well and at this stage you
know you've
by side like vm's working alongside
container exactly environment assuming
all the networking pieces are in place
below and you have this common network
fabric you know and that's the value
that nsx from from vmware brings is that
you can have this common network fabric
across containers in PM's now you're
able to start thinking about alright you
know I want to keep my databases of VM
because that's stateful right right and
you I have these stateless components of
my application that can that don't
really rely on storage as much and and
can be containerized and re platformed
and that's what we're doing here is in
it's kind of like this hybrid world or
the application is living as containers
and also as a VM to write and and so
this you know this thing zooming this is
a old monolithic heritage application
that that that there are some some
benefits that the app tier and the web
tier can get out of being akin to
exactly so let's say in that VM like you
mentioned we had all three tiers what if
we break apart a front-end that that can
really take advantage of things like
cloud auto scaling capabilities and the
fact that you can distribute that cloud
application across datacenters you know
all over the world where IBM cloud has
data centers basically allowing that
front-end that's not you know stateful
it's a stateless application to take
better advantage of cloud native
concepts right away right whereas congos
legacy apps those VMs where you have to
start thinking about refactoring if you
wanted to make them cloud native and I'm
changing that that stateful layer those
might take some more time right so
that's that halfway step that
modernization stuff exactly this is the
in-between phase and really this is this
this part of the story here is really
what the value of lift shift and
transform is is that customers are doing
this at their own pace it's not a sushi
roll of a solution that they need to
take a bite of the whole thing
altogether whether there's pieces of
that sushi they don't like right so they
they're able to take it step by step
here and in a way that makes sense to
them that fits their strategic goals
right and and you know there's there's
some other numbers out there there's 50
million DMS that are still out there in
the world today right and a lot of the
most business applications still run on
VM so I think it's it's wise to realize
that the future will still have VMs in
it and we'll probably see scenarios like
this where we have databases living in
VM still but you have all the that
client interfacing parts of
application all containerized and able
to introduce new functionality to it
right right I mean there's still some
capabilities out there that were written
you know and like the 70's and 80's that
are still chugging along that no one
wants to go in there and change those
out exactly and like we talked about
back there that you know they're the
people that actually wrote the teams
that wrote those applications they're
long gone they're right and it's it's
it's blossom translations so I'm
guessing you know you hinted at where
you're going with this last days here
the end of all of this modernization
phase we're gonna have cloud native very
young so by this point you know we've
kind of decoupled the application from
virtual machines altogether at least the
parts that that were that are you know
in in containers now so we don't really
need to rely on on hypervisors as much
anymore we can kind of that's the
application is abstracted enough that we
can start taking advantage of higher
value services like open shift as a
service so you don't really have to rely
on the the actual hardware anymore you
can take advantage of this services like
that IBM cloud provides that make
OpenShift more of like an endpoint right
where you're only bursting as much
OpenShift capacity that you need for
your application to to run and to
develop with it so let me draw this out
here so you have your application here
and it's running now on let me leave it
cloud native native that's right so this
is kind of when you you know you've
phased out some of those legacy
applications right many of your assets
aren't required to run as a VM anymore
right so then and then you're taking
advantage of let me get my green marker
here of services like our managed
kubernetes service here and also now
that you're at this cloud native
development stage you can start taking
advantage of other micro services and
you yourself have turned your
application into micro services too
right so that it's just working much you
know where you've achieved this cloud
native development state right so there
were taken advantage of you know we have
machine learning capabilities higher
value ai those capabilities that really
enable you like kind of like we
mentioned to create more engaging
applications applications that are
connecting to your end-users just a
little bit better right so mad this was
really helpful to be able to actually
sketch this out and show how you know
every step
the way with would be inverse solutions
with VMware solutions on IBM cloud your
supported kind of every phase of that
modernization path right if you have any
questions please drop us a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please like and subscribe and
don't forget you can always get started
in the cloud at no cost by signing up
for a free IVM cloud account